isabelle morini-bosc vous êtes fait
draguer suis largué au milieu d'un lac
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé un homme
youtube alors c'était l'année de mon bac
de français n'ont qu'à 75 ans comme ça
devait pas lire g soleure
j'étais c'était très heureuse de très
flatteur parce qu'il y avait un garçon
20 m 95 kg était basketteur qui
s'appelait jean et qui me courtisait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup car bien
évidemment je n'avais pas la gueule que
j'ai ouïe est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est super compliqué parce que
j'étais frisé comme un mouton alors que
c'était la mode des cheveux raides et
dont je les cache et les gens n'avaient
une énorme masse mais caché sous un banc
mana et ce garçon mais bon je vais te
faire une déclaration splendide sur un
lac dans un bateau si tu mets tes vrais
cheveux et je me suis dit merde pas
arrivé mais je me croizet et une copine
qui était coiffeuse me prête une superbe
paire 2 coeurs avec les ballons comme ça
mais magnifique que je fixe toujours
avec le petit émana idrissou sur le
bateau mathlouthi short tout emballé
dessus manif ressayre déposant sur
lionel en apnée la myriade de douilles
peut faire défaut c'est bon alors une et
mieux du petit lac de savoir lac
d'aiguebelette où s'entraîne l'équipe
dames iran
[Applaudissements]
il aimait nous être très grand et très
bien bâti tout point de vue et aveugle
là il était
à la pelouse je n'ai pas de lourdeur je
savais pas que c'était vraiment fond tu
vois et encore
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai alors ça elle a l'art est la
raison des salades roissy et dont il
prend la ras il donne un grand coup il
me fracassait la moitié du visage et
surtout il emporte la perruque je me
suis retrouvé comme une conne avec
toutes mes petites frisure et là il m'a
regardé mais j'avais l'impression d'être
un monstre effet à non je peux tout
pardonner sauf qu'on manque me suis
plongée n'importe que les rames et 3e
des deux elles sont géniales
j'ai commencé à ramer non mais encore
fourré latin il est encore sur le lac un
merci ne vous laisser pas mal
franchement n'y pas d'histoire a été
bonne
il a pris les rencontres pourquoi de
cette plus forte et clairement faire
emmerder
oui on va le retrouver
vous avez toujours un problème à clichy
oui bah oui c'est vrai ah oui bah
écoutez là mon ami prochains jours nous
écoute je sais que ça rame pour toi les
chéris alors alors qu'il s'est fait je
me suis fait draguer par justin bieber
c'est sûr que chez vous sur ces vous
ouais pas vous ah non
comme annoncé procéder ces bons récole
égaux qu'ils assez on s'est croisé deux
fois fois paris et une fois à cannes et
la faune s'est vue sur paris on est
jetés avec des amis et il est parti voir
des potes à lui il a dit oui
ramenez moi el moudja ça m'a pas trop
cul ouais et donc il va revenir vous
avec un original sur un plateau - voilà
terrain mais je suis parti voir avec des
copines et il nous parlait pas trop nous
conte ses 10 bat hull et pas rigolo donc
on est retourné faire notre soirée et je
le recroise l année la prime
ouais et là il m'a dit cette fois-ci
danse pour moi non il faut que je lui ai
dit mais à jamais la vie en fait mais
alors les bains et du coup ils étaient
vexés
hall a demandé à ce que je quitte
l'endroit où on
j'aime bien courir
oui voilà c'est assez triste comme
l'histoire passe à austin bieber
ah oui c'est un goujat c'est un goujat
yoplait j'ai dragué trois personnes en
une heure gène exact mais c'était il ya
longtemps et je reconnais que c'est une
erreur de débutant c'est je savais pas
encore que quand draguer une fille
fallait attendre d'avoir un vent pour
draguer une fille c'est en boîte de nuit
et du coup j'ai commencé à draguer après
je suis vieux j'aime et je suis reparti
avec mes potes et je me suis pas rendu
compte qu'en fait par hasard
je m'explique toujours pas la fille
avait été séduite chacune des filles et
du coup la soirée s'est terminée en
boîte
mes trois filles non non pas du tout
apprendre ce qu'on sait et on s'est
retrouvés les trois filles a sorti de la
boîte qui elle m'attendait
ouais et se sont rendu compte que
j'avais draguer les trois et se
retrouver les trois en même temps
mais moi je suis arrivé et je savais pas
trop quoi dire ce qu'on sait qu'elle
n'avait aucune il avait trois ça mais je
m'arrête plus jamais arrivé depuis
évidemment je suis bon je passais pour
un connard elles sont parties les trois
ensemble et je suis resté comme un
combat comme d'habitude d'accord et la
chute là quand isabelle talent et pas la
chute à l'est pas
je me suis fait draguer par la personne
la plus lourde de france sas et
géraldine fusion non c'est un mois ah
ouais et agathe
ouais c'est le genre ça devrait encore
plus lourd que jean-michel je pense rien
n'allait pas c'était un c'est un dîner
organisé par des amis à moi parce que
j'étais comment dîner presque parfait
[Musique]
six amis c'était un 2014 ça fait déjà
quelques années ça mais votre petite
amie de l'époque face à vincent à bâle
un prénom tout à fait commun windsor et
donc voilà donc il me dit allez vas-y
faut que tu sortes c'est juste un dîner
peut bien aller et aime beaucoup il est
sympa bon ok donc j'arrive j'avais
jamais vu le make way et donc pendant
tout le dîner il commença une fait plein
de compliments ce qui n'était pas très
désagréable mais c'était un peu un peu
redondant et non viabilité lunettes
ouais voilà des trucs comme ça et il me
dit j'ai très envie de t'embrasser nom
qu'on était encore dit oui pendant j'ai
mangé mais lasagnes c'était horrible
donc déjà ça j'aime pas dire que vous
aimez la zone ouest a dit et donc il ne
se débine pas je dis bon là on est en
train de manger ils poussent les plats
non pas pour se pencher comme ça pour
essayé de m'embrasser et l'eyepet parce
que du coup il renverse le verre d'eau
non tombe sur moi donc bonjour je suis
j'en ai marre vraiment et il me dit ah
t'es déjà mouillé
non il faut les laisser le courroux de
france fhf
[Rires]
ah ouais je fais nous là moi je vais
rentrer chez moi me sécher tu vas aller
pour l'instant c'est jean-michel la dent
may on aime bien mais bon je me suis
fait draguer par le conjoint d'un ami
henri nana c'est assez horrible moi je
pense que c'est géraldine maillet n'ont
toujours pas gilles verdez un nom
valérie benaïm
j'avais commencé normand c'était la
barre médiatique il admet la pièce
montée et la robert béjaouis qui
arrivent elles ont été pires que ça
parce que c'est une amie qui m'est très
cher qui met l'eau un bien cela
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tranquillement tv la banque l écho qu
[Rires]
est-ce que donc et elle était très très
heureux de présenter son nouveau mec
voilà et donc je me rends chez elle pour
un apéro après sympa avec plein de monde
et ce fameux nouveau type
et donc elle me le présente elle me dit
à quel point auparavant elle m'avait dit
à quel point il était formidable génial
élégant intelligent etc
sauf que dès qu'il y avait des cas elle
avait le dos tourné pour aller chercher
les petits fours pour aller apporter de
à boire il venait me paraît alors elle
me dira en tirant les cheveux qui me
trouvais absolument géniaux qui
pensaient qu'ils s'étaient trompés
c'est là le nom mais c'est terrible
qu'est ce que vous faites est ce que
vous dites avoir 1000 boul oui grave
c'est ouais et ben en fait coup de bol
c'est un coup de boule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai prétexté que j'étais hyper mal
malade et que je savais pas ce que
j'allais faire ce qu'il fait après de
sévères baisses mois deux minutes voilà
après on se voit tout ce que tu veux
mais là j'ai des remontées tapas du
maroc ce nom et que sais je suis parti
appelle à l'aise mais est en fait
croître aucun autre homme trois semaines
ou un mois et demi après la larguer
parce qu'elle l'a chopé en train de
draguer en entrée en ouest et une autre
animatrice je sais qu'il ya dix ans et à
ce moment là je lui ai dit qu'on s'est
pas vu depuis un petit bout de temps
parce que j'étais un peu gêné puis tous
ces enfants ont installé soit la plus
pourrie c'est toujours l'histoire touche
j'ai provoqué un accident pour draguer
gilles verdez non mais j'y vais résoudre
benjamin c'est moi ouais c'est vous le
jour se lève sur le parking
[Applaudissements]
le jour qui se lève sont partis par qui
quand on est deux jours ou nuisent à
laloubère et la marche généralement nous
sommes au printemps dans les années 90
au centre commercial des ulis je vous
avais déjà raconté que j'avais habité
dans ma voiture sur le parking
mais je vous avais pas dit l'anecdote la
plus folle parce que j'en avais honte et
je vais me confesser ce soir tous les
matins il y avait une superbe femme qui
sans doute travailler au centre
commercial qui venait de garer sa
voiture
à l'époque je n'avais pas l'aura que
j'ai aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas non il
a été alors je ne savais pas comment
l'aborder et je me suis dit stupidement
stupidement mais que la méthode dont
peut-être parler avec elle c'était
d'emboutir sa voiture
c'est stupide essayons 12 est un abruti
donc elle est partie travailler mais
j'ai avancé mois nature et boum j'ai
tapé dans son pare chocs avant et là le
sort de la voiture elle fait lundi
mokdad grecque
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
puis 120 d'ici à mai
alors et donc et comme elle travaillait
effectivement au centre commercial
le soir elle est revenue elle a vu que
sa voiture et j'ai dit écoutez je vous
ai attendu toute la journée
je suis désolé on va faire un constat
est là elle est rentré dans une colère
folle elle m'a dit mais vous êtes un
sale connard et j'ai dit vous avez
raison
oui et là on a fait un constat les
parties elle m'a dit et demain vous
changer de place de parking
non alors c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
donc à ma place je crois aussi la
madrague et un nom allait elle et elle
est belle et elle est pas mal alors le
vote comme la vôtre est encore la plus
pourrie mais vous vous décidément vous
êtes comme starsky et hutch vous gagnez
toujours à la fin non mais il a toujours
ce truc tu vois qui fait qu'il gagne
vous êtes vous est pas une histoire qui
se termine bien un jour non alors
attention je me suis fait draguer par un
ministre moi je pense que c'est
christine kiwi moi c'est sûr mais en
fait il n'était pas ministre encore il
est devenu après j'étais présentatrice à
lci à l'époque et j'ouvre ma mon ma
boîte aux lettres on recevait son
courrier et tout les jours je voit une
carte postale louvre d'un politique une
lettre super enflammé bon quand tout le
monde connaissait évidemment mais qu'ils
étaient mariés donc au dessus du bon ça
mais c'est quand même un peu choquant
enfin ça passe non qu'on peut pas le
chaînon pasaran on peut pas le savoir
je veux le faire postale mais après je
rentre à la maison je montre à mon mari
qui est hacké furieux évidemment il m'a
laissé de pia il était furieux membres
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était trop jaloux lci mais en fait je
regarde cette lettre mais une lettre
enflammée un truc de dingue
et puis après bon j'oublie des gens
passent etc et puis je vois traîner sur
la table des présentatrices une carte
comme la mienne du même du même ma
politique
oui les mêmes mots non mais en plus
non mais c'était en plus ça et
finalement il avait fait à toutes les
présentations
alors après il est devenu ministre il ne
l'est plus aujourd'hui je rassure les
filles les plus sexy mais c'est mais
j'ai été très choqué de voir comment
après que la lettre est ce qu'il est
juste de droite ou de gauche de gauche
et c'est pas dsk
mais c'était apprennent avec toutes les
filles on en arrête les bonnes histoires
je gagne quoi j'avais appris très vite
apprendre que je ne gagne jamais bonjour
je me suis fait draguer pas un ou une
mariée succès castaldi annoncé qu issa
guèye simge ninja vous c'est moi
non c'est pas la peine de gueuler il est
tout content quoi c'est vrai mais vous
savez que j'ai assuré pendant des années
des sonorisations de mariage y avait une
petite option madjid on qu'ils avaient
pris l'option d'être ici c'est en
picardie c'était il ya cinq ans je me
présente qu'il a à peu près 23 heures
vous n'y avez de la mariée et le marié
les bonjour bienvenue voilà je vous fais
un petit tour devait disparaître foulard
abracadabra est en fait il était un peu
saoul il avait souvent sous le soupçon
touraine voilà j'avais pas mal mais
j'étais saoul
ouais le sous sol souple et n'ont pas
compris le principe du tour est un
moment la mariée elle me regarde
elle me fait ça juste qu elle avait su
se marie à côté mais à mon avis elle
avait vu elle avait juste un petit peu
de vin qui le regardait avec des yeux de
nom
sautez féline je termine le tour je me
dis je reviens dans un instant à tout de
suite et puis finalement je suis jamais
revenus d'accor est donc l'histoire ce
termine comme ça elle s'est servie comme
ça je cherchais la chute mais bon marché
saillon perdez votre là je ne sais pas
draguer par kylie minogue sa série
castle
oui là c'est benjamin et toi alors alors
tu pas bien hongrie ayasse la plus haute
parce que ça fait plusieurs fois que je
vous dis tout fait draguer par des meufs
avec ses coûts des meubles des anglais
tony chan au pur fernand des almadies
out of you were altadena tadic ou alors
on fait ce que vous produisez pour m6
une gare want to fuck your house de fuck
you
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
coire et des moyens tu ressens mais on
avait on avait une séance photo ensemble
lequel rapport avec toi parce que
j'espérais à l'époque je présente
émission
non parce que dans mes genre parce que
dans médée décédé kylie minogue turing
ben jawad mais à l'époque c'était une
émission pour m6 qui s'appelait jet set
les narines invité principal
on a fait une séance photo ce qu'on
avait fait la couverture d'un magazine
très important et donc ça a duré pendant
plusieurs heures et on était dans un
hôtel et elle m'a fait un rentre dedans
mais de dingo non pour finir par me
diras want to fuck you non hélas et ses
fruits puisque j'étais déjà marié à
l'époque travail chez folio essais à ton
frère est toujours malade et franchement
ils ont franchement j'aurais dû y aller
non mais bien pâlichon tube non non non
non à mon avis vous auriez vous savez
très très sympa très sympa est votre
enquête non mais c'est vrai pour moi
maintenant c'est se sait moins mais
vraiment un exilé pana il est vénère non
mais aujourd'hui elle est beaucoup de
couples font ce qu'ils appellent des des
fuck liste de stars il s'autorise l'un
et l'autre de faire un petit pas de côté
si la statistique star ticket sur la
fameuse 0 je connais sa faim mon avis
c'est lorsque la lisca plus longue ça
doit être cette de matching je me suis
fait draguer par boris becker donc il en
reste un wind c'est vous ouais bah oui
new york alors boris becker en rappel
c'est un ancien joueur de tennis
boubekeur et une photo la bad a gagné le
toit
il a gagné le droit qu'est ce qu'elle a
dit l'autre il est pas beau ça pète ça
doit de votre style indie rock un peu
troublant il évoquera veille alors que
les blancs
donc 1,6 et moi la cua société nous
faire chier oui alors et alors je suis à
new york
on est en 1999 j'ai en train de voir un
virgin mojito dans un bar qui s'appelle
panique bas fringe suit avec mac os
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va les battre moi j'étais au tout va
bien je siroter un petit 6 rodange fait
des placements de produits ou nous deux
mais normes elles étaient mannequins m'a
dérangé des produits ce restaurant est
fermé depuis très longtemps et donc
c'était pendant l'us open et moi comme
j'adore le tennis j'aime chaque année à
l'us open comme elle était mannequin je
vivais à new york
les mannequins avaient l'habitude de se
réunir dans ce bar il y avait aussi tous
les joueurs de tennis fera voilà est
donc effectif alors qu il a commencé à
courtiser dans le bar ouais bon moi je
le trouvais très très beau non
oui parce que j'adorais comment il
tombait sur le gazon de wimbledon
c'était très séduisant il roulait il est
des roulades si vous avez vécu fait des
roulades aller aux turcs
c'est vrai qu'après choix mais qui fait
de la gym au sol pas pareil là une
raquette quand même vraiment déconné way
pour vous dire qu'il est parti avec moi
il est parti avec ma meilleure amie de
l'époque était mannequin kazakh qui
s'appelait votre cas kazan s'appelait
avocat et lui il s'appelait pas mu par à
l'époque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]